ファーうあぁそうアー
[拍手]
靴ははず施設ですツイッター読まなきゃ会いたいなぁ会いたいでついも共にイベントを
開けるのはいつになるんだろうかっていうこんな世の中なんで大家にいることがとても
増えると思うんですけども
最近寒すぎないですか全国の皆さん寒くないですか
正直にいえば晶石寒すぎて実は何もやる気が出ませんなぜで皆さん安心してください
最近ね
る時間めっちゃ増えてます今ライフや人間冬眠した方がいいじゃないかと思ってるん
ですよねこんな寒いのにずっとネクタイのに人が多くてやらなきゃいけない仕事があっ
たり作業があったりゲームとかなる
原そんな皆さんに朗報で素晴らしい代とは別受けてきました
そちら yeah
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
うーんこちら外国の商品なら別れてないんですけども
着る毛布でこれでのアプリゲーム用の着る毛布らしくても何回すごいって書いてあり
ましたねこれはべき3月散った計画のステー奉仕でいけない状況ならばなるべく家で
快適な生活をしたいそれの夢を叶えた最強商品なんて俺ならこのついてきた冊子見ても
もう祭神の芸人ですね
ず家をするスペースがすごい進化してるよーっていうそういうやつですよね
すごいゲーミング目やって言われてるんだ多分これのことなんですね起きる動くなんて
のゲーミングウェアだ
全身を抜く堀でカバー
あーこれ逆効果なダメ人間作る奴だなこれやばいぞこれ
一生きよえすごいじゃあちょっとこれ好きてみます
傘冰讃
大和久高い部位っていつ誰がいい
はいやばいめっ
ああもう完全にすっぽり間にすっぽりなっちゃうねこれやこれ明日にポケットがついて
んだをこれ最強じゃねこれ
機でもってからダメキって呼ばれてるシーンですよ筆頭をダメにする部屋着
ダメギですこれ待ってすっ月給を超すいいんですけどちょっと徒然と説明しますね
色んな
効果がありましてまず顔まであったらヘッドギアべて途中であげるのもよしがってあげ
て首元まであった区住吉の魚からすっぽりかぶったらもう本当にあったかいですで
マイクロファイバー生地だからめっちゃ来ちゃったかいいですよで見てこのあ仕事
もう靴下買って入りませ普通に足も立ってるんですよおいても出せるしスってこういっ
たてもあったらいいです
やばいなこれ靴下手袋ニットキャップネックをまあ全て搭載されてます w 出版
何を言ってるんだお世話を待って5個でちゃっかりと思ったらここではさっくがるで
パチンコだけだしますこうやって渡英する時も桜がこの女の人どうすんだちょっと行わ
れちゃうわかんですけどて男の人は基で作ってなんてこっクラスでだけますと路線
さっきで丸来合計面にね夢10版き魂を取るせてる
終えうんこでも対応する過去レスならず女性の人もいけるぞこれ
脱がなくてもトイレ dqn 対する遠い農薬
オレはー
ワーコレなんてすごい好ま超えて売ってることができるぞ
まずマジすごいぞみんなこれが時代の最先端です脱ぐ必要がなく何でも出来るは評価も
高い子326件の評価つ欲しい4.5みんなめっちゃ入っておりますねで見て晴れパ
こうやってねあーちゃんとか見たらこうやってこれ着てゲームすると可愛らしいん
でしょうねああああああ
いいショット変えずちょっとゲームする時ももちろんですけど普通にこれだけで出れ
そうですこれは史上最強の大メディアなぁ
ちょっと俺は大ゲームよくやってるんで早く将来これ着てこれいってゲームしようと
思います行ってきます
ブーブーよ
表もしっかりとゲーム実況をやっていきますよよし
みますじゃあさっそく今日は公約をやっていきたいと思います今日はね
一になるまでやっていこうと思います感あるなぁ
わー
[音楽]
eleanor